si je prends le contre-exemple n'importe
qui dirait un dixième de ce que dirait
xénon ils seraient bannis de l'antenne
publique mais neil n'a pas pu chanter
qu'à la rue des propos complotistes je
rappelle que texte a été texte a été
viré pour des blagues une blague d une
blague les voilà jean marie bigard ceux
présents sur tes pmp a eu des spectacles
annulés parce que il a fait aussi
l'anglais cma à nourrir bizarrement
c'est de ces deux c'est ccc deux fois
c'est sûr c'est sûr tpm ps vous avez
aussi vous voulez vous voulez vous
débarrasser des gens vous sûr que ce
sera l invité il va venir deux fois dans
ta vie mais vous et je la vis à vis bien
il sera sortie directe on sait qu'on
n'entendra plus parler 3 millions dans
la gueule est terminée on va vite et
serré les sourires et next que c'était
un intellectuel qu'il a des références
qu'il est intelligent qui est un des
batteurs liberté expression on lui
permet de dire les choses les plus
horribles ne vous inquiétez pas eric
zemmour il a des tribunes il est avec
monsieur naulleau il a fait de la radio
een écrit il il a publié des livres donc
vous inquiétez pas eric zemmour il
existe et eric zemmour il a le droit de
détester les musulmans il a le droit ne
pas aimer les homosexuels et la droite
d'avoir aidé et révisionniste mais ce
que les chaînes ont cette responsabilité
de diffuser ses idées
la première question est là et j'en veux
à eric naulleau lorsqu'il dit à charles
d'endurer les idées d'eric zemmour comme
elle existe dans la société il faut
qu'il existe lui dans le débat public
moi j'ai reçu une lettre à mon cabinet
ah oui exactement après dans l'ue dans
l'art est professionnel non mais voilà
il y aura peut-être un peu près une
lettre ça la wii select attendait la wii
alors alors toulouse le 15
bajeux dès octobre un bon comédien
mohamed le professeur jacques bernès a
lancé un appel urgent pour soigner les
coeurs kurdes
il a besoin de médecins bien sûr c'est
mieux de faire l'autiste chez hanouna
pourtant c'est des [ __ ] qui
souffrent c'est arras d'accord quand tu
regardes tes gosses es tu fier quant au
voile nous sommes fiers de monsieur
zemmour 7 fatima doit repartir dans son
pays arabes avec toi aussi en ta
présence nous partons chez quotidien bah
on n'a pas besoin de vous qu'ils
arrêtent ou qu'ils apprennent à écrire
français le maire essaie d'être
selligent et regarde ta gueule bah il
est très beau certainement plus beaucoup
à la télé tu ressembles à un des
assassins
zemmour du coup la parole va se libérer
peut-être qu'un jour on aura des acteurs
enlever nos salles des classes mais
voilà les propos d'eric zemmour soit un
support à lever de la photo il
elle s'en est pas moins de répondre
alors eric naulleau siliana ce qu il y
en a qui tuent aujourd'hui au nom des
tests de zemmour sur le web mais
attendez eric naulleau qui va répondre
parce que nos deux à s'adresser mujica
déception s'il vous plaît il s'adresser
quand même à eric naulleau surtout et à
vous et vous allez lui réponds oui alors
entièrement moi d'abord je devrais dire
j'ai reçu plusieurs lettres ce genre
autre argument la dernière je les lui en
famille on s'est bien marré ah oui ça
pas l'huile et des lui ledit match aller
les gars
[Applaudissements]
jérôme r à table jégo l'insu de van zyl
ouais c'est ça te fait rire moi je suis
mis en cause la même heure je trouve
inacessible je te dis ce que je fais
avec ce genre de lettre mais contrat de
lannion sérieux mais voilà maintenant on
va pas le traité [ __ ] à mes yeux je
pose des questions et d'autres c'est
notre est debout dans l'autre sens et
dans l'autre sens et c'est l'essai le
répond me saute ensuite tous les gens
que tu as cité qu'en été mis en cause je
les ai défendu publiquement cac soitec
ce et les autres donc je travaille pas
avec eux je peux vérifier dans les
dossiers puisque tu as l'air d'avoir une
âme policière ce soir vérifier dans les
dossiers ensuite je trouve ça
inadmissible que quand quelqu'un n'est
pas d'accord avec toi c'est parce qu'il
défend des intérêts particuliers
non mais c'est inadmissible mais je me
remets transit même si oui mais oui mais
c'est maintenant ramène à ce qu'on se
remet de tous on se promet d'être eric
on se remet d accusation extravagant
grieg et je trouve inadmissible au moins
avec dégoût restent les bras croisés
alors qu'on n'arrête pas de le
contredire et de le combattre je les
fais rue
dans la première émission des rôles là
on l'admiré d'écouté il n'a pas voulu
revenir sur ses douves une pareille pour
lui claire regarder ça mais bon mais bon
c'est génial et je rejoins les bras
croisés mais moi mais il n'a rien contre
vous il prouve la cession aux as raison
aussi virile